LeBron just from a leadership
perspective what's the message to your
teammates right now down O3 uh I may
just got to get one just one at a time
you know just focus on game four and um
you know that's all you can that's all
you can really think about I mean
obviously this game is over in done with
we have some opportunities but we didn't
come through so just get ready for
Monday and uh you just gotta get one and
it's one game uh series for us or every
game counts obviously
one
LeBron you guys had a I think a one or
two point lead
more importantly one point lead uh then
they won on an 11-0 run yeah
back-to-back turnovers and they hit two
threes just call the time out it was
that was the game yeah I guess what'd
you see in that was the game with
back-to-back turnovers after we went up
and made two free throws we went up one
and we had back-to-back turnovers and
they hit back-to-back threes made us
take a time out we never got back in
rhythm
LeBron this team has been in kind of
fighter fight for survival mode for
months oh for sure um
there been any build up from that in
terms of like you guys having to be so
locked in for what 40 games now or 50
games yeah we still are we still are and
um you know we got to come in obviously
tomorrow and watch film and be upset and
be disappointed in whatever the case may
be and uh and and use that and use some
of the the miscues or whatever the case
may be in there also some of the things
that we did well to apply to game four
you know and um you know that's all you
can worry about
LeBron what's Denver doing in this
series so far that's allowed them to be
successful like obviously you guys face
from the Conference Finals a couple
years ago they've All-Stars accomplished
players on their team but where do you
think the edge has been for them
uh I mean obviously Jamal was fantastic
in the first half today he got him off
to a great start and even with that we
were only down three at the half I think
it's been the timely Shots by their role
players
um obviously I think the kcp the Michael
Porter Juniors the Bruce Browns
um even Jeff you know hit a big time
timely shot today you know when we were
kind of going on a run so I think he's
been here Supporting Cast have kind of
made those timely shots
um that's uh you know allowing them to
kind of have the edge
Melissa hey Braun uh you guys had a 0.3
written on the Whiteboard uh very
recently signifying your chances of
making the playoffs you guys did anyways
obviously the odds of coming back from a
three to nothing deficit or even tougher
but is that belief still there I mean it
should be I hope so
um you know I don't know can't speak for
the guys right now because I don't know
what's going on through all their minds
right now but I still do
um so you know as time going right back
home and start to refuel and start the
treatment treatment process and recovery
process and get ready for Monday so my
mindset is always locked in as if it's a
game one
Steve Brian follow-up to that the only
way you can win this is to make history
you've made history so many times before
you know the game uh does that thought
even cross your mind that that's the
only way you can do it and you'd like to
make history again obviously of course
that's the only mindset for me for sure
last question Rachel
with him in particular
uh I mean once he gets going it's kind
of hard to to turn him off I mean
obviously
um you know he got going from the very
beginning we watched One One Clip at
halftime where we allowed him to see the
ball go in because we didn't match up a
transition in early in the first quarter
and he had one from their left wing by
their bench a wide open shot and a guy
that has that type of Rhythm and we all
know I mean Jamal is one of those guys
in our league that if you
he'll run off 20 and a quarter or 30 and
a half that's what he did tonight so you
know everyone in our league knows that
especially when he gets going against
the bouncing and shooting them you know
the three balls shooting the mid-range
you know posting up smaller guards where
he has he can score at all three levels
of the game from the paint you know from
the free-throw line and also from the
three-point line so
um you tip your head he's a hell of a
player